c'est elle joli on vient d'y regarder
pour la première fois c'est surtout les
enfants qui voulaient passer par cette
route pour les voir ça change de
l'ordinaire et ton nom sympathique un
éclairage qui se veut également
écologique
la quasi totalité des communes des
départements sont désormais passés à
l'éclairage led la vie de plaisirs a
pris le virage des 2009 plaisir est très
étendue et on mettait sur chaque
candélabres que ce soit en gâtine à la
mare au sol là où à la boissière dans
les rues
on mettait beaucoup de partout des
l'irlande des mots petit et tout et
s'avérait que ça revenait très cher
madder et tout ça donc on a dû j'étais
arrivé à 150000 euros le budget annuel
est désormais de 92 mille euros et la
facture d'électricité pour la ville est
passée de 3877 euros durant les fêtes de
2009 à 394 euros aujourd'hui grâce aux
leds autres bénéfices le led a une durée
de vie 10 fois supérieure aux éclairages
classiques
fini les ampoules constamment en panne
qu'il faut régulièrement changé et a
permis de passer aux motifs en trois
dimensions d'avoir plus de couleurs et
de choix le changement et l'innovation
sont les bienvenus ils sont là de
bonheur mais c'est bien samed la gaieté
et les enfants les aiment bien ah oui
c'est vrai j'ai vu ce matin en allant
bulls ont installé un petit ours
l'intimité tonnes pour autant depuis
trois ans seules les entrées de la ville
la mairie le marché et les ronds points
sont ornés de décorations ici à plaisir
les illuminations dans chaque quartier
c'est du passé car les installations de
ses décors en location restent onéreuses
et malgré les fêtes et l'ambiance
festive qui sert attachent leur reste à
vous tous à l'économie